[Music]
hello and welcome to this ai
ml demo derby session what we've got for
you today is three back to back demos
showing off interesting ways that you
can use machine learning to solve
problems
i'm going to be kicking things off with
a quirky project
that will help my friend watch movies
more safely let's get straight into it
so the project i name
phobia safe videos with machine learning
this sounds a bit weird so let me give
you a bit of a backstory as to what this
is all about
so a while ago i was watching some
movies with some friends
and i discovered that one of my friends
actually has a very serious phobia of
swans now it's not actually swans but i
want them to watch this video and feel
safe watching
it so we were watching some classic
movies so everyone else knew exactly
when the swans were going to appear
and so we would just tell our friend
exactly when to look away and then they
wouldn't need to get super scared
now this worked pretty well until
sometimes we got it wrong
and people got upset so i figured i
could potentially use machine learning
to solve this problem
now there's actually only a couple of
tools that we need to solve this problem
and one of them is called the cloud
video intelligence api
this is a very powerful api that allows
you to just detect what's in a video
using machine learning
and in fact you don't need to know
anything about machine learning to use
it you just feed it a video and it tells
you what's inside the video
it has a couple of really interesting
features that you can find out more
about in the docs
the next tool that could be useful for
this problem is called the transcoder
api
now this is a very powerful video
processing api
and a classic example of this is on
youtube
where you've got the option to watch a
video in different levels of quality
you've got like standard definition high
definition 4k
this api allows you to feed in a raw
video and it will
automatically output all the different
formats
for streaming over the web all for you
it has this and it has a couple of other
really interesting features useful for
video processing on the web
so looking at these two tools there is a
couple of interesting features that we
can just plug together to potentially
solve this problem
we've got the label detection feature of
the video intelligence api
that will tell you what's in a video
during what time segments
so for example if we want to detect
swans it will potentially tell us
from 10 seconds to 15 seconds there's
swans in the video
we can use these time segments to then
in the transcoder api
inject a full screen overlay to hide the
swans throughout the video
and the inject overlays feature is
classically used for things like
injecting
watermarks but i'm going to use it in
this case to hide the entire screen
so let's look at the demo in action
alright so we're here in the google
cloud platform
this is my demo and let's just get into
it and upload
a scary video file
okay so the video file is uploaded let's
have a look at what it
looks like
so we can see it's a nice uh calming uh
video there's a plane taking off oh
there's a guy with a banjo
and oh my god look at that there's a
scary swan so
this is the kind of thing we don't want
we want uh this to be fixed
so how's that gonna happen well
i have a cloud function that it will
trigger
based on the bucket that i just uploaded
that video to
and this cloud function all it's doing
is taking the video and running it
through the
cloud video intelligence api and running
label detection
and it should output the labels to this
next bucket and there they are
so this is a json file with all of the
things that the video intelligence api
spotted in our video
along with the time segments that it
found them for
and now that this landed in this bucket
we have
our final cloud function which is going
to scan through all of those labels
and pick out the ones that feature the
word swan
and for the time segments that it
detects those to appear it will
feed that to the transcoder api to then
hide the screen
so let's see if it's done that
and here it is so this should be our
final
safe to watch video let's have a look
so we can see okay it starts off the
same we have a relaxing plane taking off
and then a friendly man with banjo and
oh look at this
where i previously got startled by a
swan
it has been hidden from the video view
so that's it that is the full
demo video pipeline that will make
videos safe to watch based on
anyone's individual phobia okay
so a quick recap of how things are
plugged together
i take the raw video and that gets fed
through video intelligence to run label
detection
when i've got those labels i then scan
through for the things i'm afraid of
and use the time segments to inject
overlays
using the transcoder api which then
outputs a new safe to watch video with
all the scary things hidden
a point to note is that you can't teach
the cloud video intelligence api
new things because it's all pre-trained
and static
if you have something more specific that
you're afraid of that the video
intelligence api doesn't detect
you can train your own model using a
tool like auto ml video classification
for more details and code samples of how
to do that
check the description below and i'll now
hand off to mark who's going to show you
what he's built
thank you hi my name is marco i'm a
solutions architect at google cloud
in this session i will show you a real
life example of its ai
a large car dealership has many visitors
and employees
and wants to understand people and
spaces but in a privacy-centric manner
today we will show you how the
dealership was able to understand
occupancy
and improve safety with google cloud
coral
and a technology partner called blue zoo
let's build this today
our goal is to count the number of
employees or customers entering or
exiting the premises
but to do so in a way that protects
their privacy
with its ai we can feed the raw camera
feed
straight into a machine learning model a
custom machine learning model
that we have trained to detect patterns
one pattern could be an employee leaving
through the door
and then the output of this machine
learning model are simply counters or
numbers
how many times these events happened the
raw camera feed
or images are never stored anywhere
never transmitted out of the system
and this is how we could build such a
solution on the left we have a camera
which can be
any camera and then we have the coral
development board which has the google
edge tpu machine learning accelerator
so first we will use the coral
development port and a usb webcam
to record some test footage
okay so i recorded myself walking in and
out through the door several times
and then in vertex ai i added them as a
data set
so here i am walking in that's good
now we can use the console to then draw
a bounding box around the object
like so and then we can choose which
label this one is corresponding to
this one is an event for person in
then what you need to do is click on
train new model
it's as simple as that i will select
automl it's
and then the type of model i wish to
train i wish to run it on coral devices
with the calculated cpu and i wish to
have the higher accuracy version of the
model
okay let's now export the model and
select the edge tpu tensorflow lite
compilation as the option let me now
process one of the example videos that i
recorded of myself
walking in and out using this new model
okay so we load the new model we trained
there's me working out
you may have seen a sort bleep there it
said person out it drew a bounding box
around me
there we go and there is an employee out
event so i labeled myself as an employee
here
now i'm walking in let's pay attention
okay person in
and here we go employee in one
to collect these occupancy counters we
can now connect this edge device
securely to google cloud
using iot core and then we can stream
the data payloads
all the way to a table in bigquery
here's the table schema
holding the occupancy counters and if we
query the table
we can see that there's no data so let's
now run this model
through a real test with testing footage
taken at the dealership
this footage was recorded with one
employee
and two customers entering the building
there we go transmitting inference
summary
to iot core and what did it transmit one
employee in and two customers in
so when the devices transmit data iot
core will receive them and drop them in
this pub sub topic
and then we have a simple cloud function
that is triggered by that same pop sub
topic
the function is extremely simple it will
just take the json payload
and write it into bigquery and there we
go
so the same data package that was
transmitted
by the client with numerical values
telling us that one
employee has entered and two customers
have entered during this 15 second
time period here the visualization is
built on looker using bigquery as the
data source
and in bigquery we have two tables the
first one is
from this system using machine learning
inference and the second one is from
blueso
using their occupancy sensors and then
we merge and visualize that
combined data so here we have the
dashboard so in the map of southern
california including san diego
the dealership has three blue zoo wi-fi
sensors
additionally there are 21 coral based
optical sensors over each of the
doorways
for fine-grained occupancy detection
both for visitors
and employees here the bar chart shows
the occupancy of
most of the recent week the number of
visitors in the service lounge
tells us when the lounge might exceed
capacity and finally if the sales
closing rooms are not being occupied
during much of the day
we may have a closing problem i really
hope that you enjoyed this session
thank you for watching and bye bye hi
i'm kaz developer part of get from
google cloud today i'd like to show
a tool called pdf2 audiobook
the problem was i had too many unread
pdf books
also i wanted to lose my weight how can
i solve these problems
at the same time my solution was to
build a tool that converts the pdf books
into audiobooks
by using cloud ai so that i would listen
to the audiobooks while i'm running or
exercising
so let's take a look at how pdf2
audiobook works
you can upload your pdf file on a cloud
google cloud stage bucket
and wait for 10 to 15 minutes so you'll
have the
multiple mp3 files generated this is the
audiobook content
no server management is required cloud
function is suitable for building a
small automation tool
like pdf to audiobook for implementing
the workflow or pdf to audiobook i've
written a python code like this i have
defined a function called
p2a gcs trigger that takes a file object
of pdf file uploaded on cloud straight
and pass it to the auto function to
register this to the cloud functions
you use declared functions deploy
command by specifying the function name
runtime name and trigger bucket name and
so on
once you upload the pdf file on the
trigger bucket on cloud stage
the whole process will begin it starts
with an aussie of its vision api
and then it extracts features from the
ocl result
and called automl tables for extracting
the body text
and finally call text to speech api for
generating this speech
let's take a look at the first step
vision api
this api has a wide variety of visual
analytics features
and one of them is ocr a text detection
feature
for example if you upload a single page
in a book to the api
you'll get the original result like this
the texts are grouped in a different
paragraphs
the api written the result as json
format with
various parameters of each paragraph
such as the paragraph
text x and y position of the paragraph
and etc to use vision api from your
application
you write a code like this at first you
specify the uri
of the pdf file on cloud stretch and
then switch find a uri
for saving the result.json file and call
the api
so now you have converted the pdf book
into text
but that's not the whole story as you
can see there are many parts that should
not be included
in the audiobook such as page headers
diagram labels sample code and page
numbers
we needed a way to detect each paragraph
should be included or ignored
for this classification i have used auto
email tables
this is a service allowing you to create
your machine running model for tablet
data such as
database tables or spreadsheets
automatic tables as
its name says automates a major part of
ml
development process so all you have to
do is uploading the training data
study training and wait for some hours
under the hood automatables does the
necessary tasks for data scientists
such as feature engineering model
selection
and hyper parameter tuning for pdf2
audio book
i have collected the features of the
training data from the ocl result
that includes the paragraph text
character numbers
ridges and heights x and y position of
the paragraph
and so on so that we expect the created
ml model would classify whether a
paragraph
is a body text or useless garbage text
let's take a look at
how otml table works you can start
creating the dataset at first
and choose your tabular dataset
and read it
and you can upload your local csv file
by specifying the file name
of the csv file
and press the continue button
and then you can generate statistics of
the uploaded features
so that you can check out each features
correctly uploaded with the
expected distributions and start
training the model
specifying the budget for training hours
and wait for four hours
after the training finished you'll get
an evaluation report like this
it looks like it gets pretty high
accuracy
the report also includes a confusion
matrix where you can find the accuracy
for detecting body text
is 95 percent and the accuracy for the
garbage text
is 97 this isn't so bad
if you take a look at the feature
importance you can learn the paragraph
text is the most important feature for
this ml model
finally i have used text to speech api
for generating speech data i have
defined a function like this
where you're adding ssml tags to each
paragraph
so that for example you'll hear longer
break at each section header
the listener would easily understand
that there's a new section starting
so that was the quick view of pdf2
audiobook
with this solution i was able to listen
to the majority of
red video books unfortunately the
technology doesn't seem to be
working for my weight loss
anyway if you are interested in this
please take a look at the documentations
of each product thank you so much
you